welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Jessica Pylea an assistant professor
of women's history at texas state
university-san marcos professor play Lee
is here at Yale as the human trafficking
and modern day slavery fellow at the
Gilder Lehrman Center she has authored
an article exploring the feminist
politics within the League of Nations
Committee on the trafficking of women
and children in the Journal of women's
history and another article that
examines how concerns about white
slavery served to bolster some women's
rights advocates claims that women be
included in the federal immigration
service at the turn of the century today
we talked with her about her new book
Beyond white slavery policing women and
the growth of the FBI 1902 1941 welcome
professor Pylea thank you let's begin
with an overview of your book tell us
about it what the book does is it
explores the origins and enforcement of
the white slave Traffic Act which is
popularly known as the Mann Act the US
Congress passed this law in 1910 and it
made it illegal to take a woman or a
child over state lines for the purposes
of prostitution debauchery or in the
language of the law any other immoral
purpose it fell to the young FBI to
enforce this law and as a result the
story of the enforcement of the Mann Act
and the story of the growth of the FBI
are intertwined and when I look at FB
i-- enforcement of this law what i find
is that it was used to police
prostitution which was one of its stated
goals but it was also used to police
domesticity so we see the FBI
investigating cases of seduction false
promises of marriage adultery bigamy a
whole wide range of sexual and romantic
misadventures okay and how did the book
come to be why did you feel it was
important to write it well I was very
interested in the topic of sex
trafficking it's captured the public's
interest in numerous ways our sex is
always it's everywhere top of the list
exactly and even President Obama just
recently spoke out against sex
trafficking calling at modern-day
slavery he called it an outrage the
district state
apartment has devoted quite a bit of
resources to fighting against sex
trafficking and the public you know
consume products that feature sex
trafficking all the time I've been
thinking about the Liam Neeson movie
taken and I had been interested in about
the fight against sex trafficking and
where it had first started and i
discovered that sex trafficking is a
topic that has you know been around for
a very long time and in the early 20th
century it was called white slavery
people fought against it they organized
internationally they organized
nationally in the united states 45 out
of the 48 states passed local anti white
slavery laws in addition to the national
one that I study so one of the things
that I wanted wanted to think about was
at what this history can tell
contemporary activists I wanted to speak
to them and to alert them to the fact
that they are participating in a social
movement and a political movement as
deep historical roots additionally I
also wanted to think about how gendered
habits of mind informed the growth of
the American state so what I'm referring
to there is I'm thinking about how FBI
agents when they investigate this law
brought with them their own baggage
their own perceptions of the world about
what women's proper place should be and
is and how that shaped investigations
and shaped the growth of the FBI itself
very interesting how did you do your
research the research I did I did
research everywhere I traveled to
archives in Geneva and London and
Minneapolis Fort Worth Portland and all
points in between but the vast majority
of the of my records that I use the most
our house with the National Archives in
Washington DC mostly FBI records okay
well actually there's some really
interesting stories about that I use
about 1,000 a sample of 1,000
investigations out of there's many many
more there probably you know 60,000
investigations that were conducted
between 1910 and 1941 and one of the
things that I thought was very very
funny that I discovered while I was
doing a research is that in 1944 J Edgar
Hoover asked that these files be
examined to see if they can be turned
over to the National Archives because
the National Archives was pestering the
FBI to you know
hand over some records and when they
were examined the man examining them
said no we can't give them over there's
too much salacious detail there's too
much going on here he said that it would
be seriously embarrassing to the FBI it
would be politically suicidal for the
FBI to hand them over now of course they
did end up handing them over at a much
later date but it's the elements that
are kind of politically suicidal or very
salacious that I find to be really
really helpful in my in my work the FBI
investigated all types of families most
of these investigations never go to
court and that's the problem from the
FBI's perspective is that they're
investigating American families and kind
of who are going through personal
tragedies but there is no kind of
prosecutorial intent so what I find or j
edgar Hoover himself said that between
1921 and 1936 that the FBI had conducted
around 47,500 investigations yet during
the same period of time you only see
around 6300 court cases emerging out of
these so by looking at the
investigations rather than US Attorney's
court cases I'm able to get a much
broader view of what it is that be I was
doing in these investigations do you
think the FBI was improperly using the
Mann Act in in many instances since the
Mann Act was originally to combat
prostitution and it really veered off
into a whole nother realm that's a
really good question they I don't think
they were misusing it from their
standards in 1917 the Supreme Court
ruled on the white slave Traffic Act to
define its scope and in that decision it
said that the any other immoral purposes
Clause really truly meant any other
immoral purpose it could be pleasure
escapades it could be Affairs it could
be anything so the FBI was kind of
operating under you know from that
ruling the other really interesting part
of this is that for the vast majority of
these investigations particularly into
marital troubles and seduction cases
were initiated by the citizens involved
Hoover says in 1932 that seventy percent
of these cases were started because
somebody goes to the FBI office says hey
I need help my daughter has disappeared
or my wife has run off and so I don't
really look at this law as a
heavy-handed FBI top-down surveillance
law okay instead its citizens who are
begging for help and the FBI is there
and they have the jurisdiction to be
able to track people down and in many
ways the FBI doesn't really want to be
doing this I mean in 1939 they pull back
and say you know we can't we don't have
the resources we don't have the time we
don't have the budget to be getting
involved in that I am like quibbles
right investigate every wife who leaves
her husband goes across state line yeah
how does your work differ from much of
the other stuff that's out there that's
a great question most of the stuff
that's about white slavery examines the
popular culture artifacts the movies the
plays this was a very popular topic the
Reformers activism and most of it most
of the historians who do this work look
at white slavery and they look at it use
it as a lens to analyze a whole host of
anxieties fears of interracial sex fears
of immigration fears of women taking to
the streets demanding the right to vote
or women working in factories and so
they use it as a way to talk about other
cultural changes that are occurring
between nineteen hundred and nineteen
thirty and most of them do not look at
enforcement they don't they stop there
they look it up until the laws passed if
they look at enforcement at all they
look at a jack johnson case which is a
very celebrated case where the african
american boxer Jack Johnson he was
probably the world's most famous athlete
at the time really I'm not familiar with
this okay yeah and I prosecuted for what
for violating the white slave Traffic
Act because he had taken a girlfriend
who was a prostitute but they had a more
of a romantic relationship he had taken
her across state lines was she black her
was she was white okay so that was the
biggest that's the big issue and he was
convicted and he fled and you know left
the United States because he didn't want
to serve the time and traveled
throughout the world until eventually he
returned to the United States has served
his year in prison so most people talk
about the persecution of Jack Johnson as
a way
that this law was misused to uphold a
racial caste system that severely
punished non white men for having sexual
access to white women so when we talk
about enforcement that's the only case
that really gets brought up or perhaps
the prosecution of Charlie Chaplin and
other celebrities I'm looking at just
the regular cases where the they're more
run-of-the-mill cases I end up looking
at a completely different dynamic yes
interracial sex was very much policed
and I see that in my you know in my
evidence homosexual no no not really
which is interesting because in the
1920s the 1930s places like New York
City had a thriving you know kind of gay
scene and it's not really policed these
are very heterosexual Oh classes so
whoever didn't use the Mann Act really
that uh fascinating no and in some ways
the issue of homosexuality from the US
federal government isn't as present
prior to World War two I mean the
Immigration Bureau is keeping an eye and
enforcing kind of anti-gay policies at
the borders but you know the amount of
people that they're excluding is very
very small it's not until World War two
that we see kind of the the US state you
know capital S state actually start
policing homosexuality very fervently
and so conclusions what do you conclude
in your book well I conclude that first
that this law was fundamental to the
growth of the FBI when the FBI was first
established or when this law was passed
in nineteen ten the FBI only had 61
special agents most of them were based
on the eastern seaboard it didn't have
very much reach and it really wasn't
doing very much wasn't you know
enforcing some antitrust legislation and
the like within five years after the
passage of the law we see that the FBI
has been expanded to over 300 cities
nationwide and it grows on the back of
the Mann Act so if you're interested in
the history of the FBI you have to
understand the Mann Act is foundational
to the FBI which also implies that
policing of sexuality and police
of women is foundational to the FBI's
bureaucratic culture the other thing
that I find is that the policing of
domesticity tells us much about ideas of
where women should be and where women
shouldn't be the fact that an
anti-prostitution law police women in
the home doesn't surprise me at all
because when you think about it women
are central to both the home and the
brothel and interesting ways and men
have the same sexual rights in both
spaces and the man that goes to both
spaces might actually be one in the same
so what we see is that women's corporal
bodies were policed using the Mann Act
whether she was a prostitute or whether
she was a wife but interestingly so were
men's respectability was also policed
the relationship of men's bodies was
closely monitored by the FBI so if a man
had an inappropriate relationship with
with a young girl he was going to come
under the you know under surveillance by
the FBI and yeah and the other thing
that I find my final conclusion is that
the fight against sex trafficking has a
deep history especially on the law
enforcement side I conclude the
manuscript with this fascinating case
study of a 1936 sex trafficking ring
that operated here in New Haven the
people involved were trafficking young
girls up from New Jersey in New York to
places like Bridgeport New Haven
Hartford and all points in between when
we look at this case or when I look at
this case I find it to be incredibly
exploited it the girls involved had no
choice than types of customers they
serviced they had no control over the
wages that their work earned that their
prostitution earned they were an
incredibly abusive circumstances yet
this was incredibly profitable for the
people involved the FBI estimated that
this particular ring earned between 1.5
and 2 million dollars a year every
single year that's that's between about
24 and 32 million dollars near my
standards right so it's incredibly
profitable and the FBI's investigation
was able to to
conclude with 39 separate convictions of
separate people involved in this when
thinking about sex trafficking today and
this 1936 case I see a lot of
similarities and i think that there's
much to be learned by looking in the
past to think about what were the
contours of sex trafficking in the past
the contours of vice markets the
contours of prostitution how did it
happen and how did law enforcement try
to fight against it is the Mann Act
still in effect today it is there was
some talk when Eliot Spitzer got in all
of his trouble of going after him with
the Mann Act although that never really
developed it seems to be currently being
used against craigslist prostitution and
you know online prostitution I think
that it's going through a period of
revivalism within the Department of
Justice so certainly it's it's a tool
that the prosecutors now use okay thank
you very much for being here with us
today and sharing some of your work
thank you so much for more information
about professor ply lee and her research
please visit our website at yale edu
slash macmillan report be sure to join
us again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale